à partir du cinquième ou sixième jour
j'ai pleuré de tous les jours en fait le
premier albatros ou juste une lumière un
nuage ou enfin juste une sensation de
quelques instants 20 voilà on est juste
bien là où on est et ça c'est des
moments de joie hyper fort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas encore trop compris ça j'étais
assez surprise de voir autant de monde
quand tu passes la ligne c'est toi qui a
réussi mais c'est aussi tous les gens
qui quittent ont suivi parce qu'ils vont
espérer avec toi pendant trois mois et
donc sur le chenal du des
sables-d'olonne n'a de voir tous ces
gens qui disaient bravo et merci
c'est quand même rare dans la vie tous
les joueurs de partager un moment de
joie avec autant de monde mais c'était
tellement tellement beau coup franc
c'était tellement beau coup que j'étais
un peu estomaqué c'est difficile à 2
d'assimiler tout ça d'un coup quoi ça
fait beaucoup
[Musique]
n'est pas de toilettes ou pas de cuisine
j'ai même pas de couches est en fait
tout est vide à l'intérieur uniquement
de l'électronique qui me permet de
piloter le bateau d'avoir internet à
bord pour prendre les fichiers météo
j'ai beaucoup de mattel de réparation du
matériel de sécurité aussi beaucoup de
quoi de manger parce qu'elle est celle
de l échelle de trois mois j'avais 180
kg de nourriture
j'avais aussi des sacs avec des habits
on est pas mal de matériel à bord mais
c'est quand même relativement vide en
fait un bateau de course et les
toilettes c'est un saut ma cuisine c'est
un réchaud à gaz et d'or alors sur un
espèce de poufs habits qui est quand
même assez grand et assez assez
confortable que je déplace d'un côté à
l'autre du bateau en fonction de deux là
lui remet ça avec la vie à bord s'adapte
à la performance
le vendée globe c'est parti le matin et
le soir à sept heures ténue et 19h team
donc universel on passe pas mal de temps
à télécharger les fichiers et à les
étudier et à choisir notre auto fonction
de sade et donc la frontière entre un
régime anticyclonique et un régime et au
régime dépressionnaire donc ça c'est
vraiment ce qui va jalonner notre
journée et puis on essaie de faire trois
repas par jour malgré tout un petit
déjeuner un déjeuner un dîner qui
ressemblent à des choses qu'on peut
manger à terre la routine c'est je sors
dehors je regarde que c'est une bateau
va bien
après chaque manoeuvre j'avais ma petite
routine je passais toujours au moins une
demi-heure dehors à regarder juste à
profiter de dehors et à regarder si tout
allait bien pour les fichiers météo tu
les prends d'une certaine façon faire là
tu te crées des repères qui sont aussi
une façon de rester humain
qui c'est une façon de contrôler ou
d'avoir l'impression de contrôler parce
qu'en fait on est quand même contre pas
grand chose quand on est bien des
endroits comme ça j'ai eu pas mal de
mouvements pour lire pour regarder même
des films alors part en part des deux
heures de films d'affilée mais on peut
regarder petits morceaux et c'est des
moments où on s'autorise à penser autre
chose qu elle son bateau ce que fait
même quand on est en train de dormir on
est en veille en fait il ya un petit
morceau de nous-mêmes qui est en train
d'écouter le bateau qu'un train de se
demander si tout va bien
ça dépend complètement des tranches ont
en fait si on regarde à l'échelle de la
planète quand on est dans l'atlantique
nord entre la france les açores
l'équateur il ya beaucoup de trafic
maritime
les systèmes météo on traverse des
sittelles météo qui font que la météo
évolue beaucoup donc là
c'est rare de dormir plus de trois quart
d'heures d'affilée mais par contre dans
les mers du sud parfois on est pendant
quatre jours en avant d'une dépression
où finalement on va rester avec les
mêmes voile ou presque ou avoir une
seule manos par jour
après c'est la terreur et quand on se
réveille après une saisie de deux heures
on a l'impression que c'était le
président
il me suis jamais vraiment porté en
danger de mort le moment qui a été le
plus dur de ce point de vue là c'est
quand un des concurrents kevin escoffier
a été a fait naufrage et a été sauvé par
un autre concurrent jean le cam ya eu
une période de quelques heures où on
savait qu'il était sur son radeau de
survie mais on savait pas exactement où
et il n'avait pas encore été totalement
récupéré et on surprend du coup bas à
fermer un peu plus de cloisons d'un
bateau à regarder à re réfléchir à ou
est positionné son matériel de sécurité
on réfléchit un peu aux procédures de
base
moi le plus gros que j'ai eue c'était
finalement c'était là en arrivant dans
le golfe de gascogne j'ai eu jusqu'à un
mètre cinquante de houle
j'ai eu des moments avec simplement cinq
mètres de creux mais des vagues beaucoup
plus courte et dans un angle par rapport
à mon bateau qui était beaucoup moins
optimale et là j'ai vraiment eu peur de
tout cas c'est ce que nos bateaux c'est
les bas taux de carbone très fin qui
tape qui résonne avec beaucoup de bruits
générés sont fêtés dans un bateau du
coup j'ai occupé à ralentir encore je
suis sortie de rome springboks des
tout-petits et ça tape là un truc de
dingue
et là c'est pas très agréable on ne
tient pas debout on est obligé d'être
allongée peux pas dormir parce qu'en
fait ça fait exactement les mêmes mots
le coeur que dans une montagne russe en
fait donc on n'arrive pas à dormir et là
on fait le dos rond et on pense à autre
chose et on attend la suite
forcément ça fait deux
c'est l'argent en plus qu'une aire
d'autoroute en termes de bruit je sais
plus exactement combien de décibels
c'est mais c'est quasiment comme être à
côté d'une machine arrivés en train de
fonctionner tout le temps et moi j'ai
quasiment tout le temps me soit des
boules quiès soit un casque antibruit
avec de la musique alors mis tout le
temps d'une certaine façon pour quand
même entendre un peu mon bateau mais
juste atténuée les sont en fait le bruit
est un des premiers indicateurs de
problème sur un bateau
moi je me suis pas posé 36 questions
j'ai juste dit ce que je pensais un peu
tout le temps je la joue tranquille ou
view
la remarque que je vous dise que je la
joue tranquille
mais bon en même temps et
je ne sais pas ce que l'avenir ailleurs
il ya une bonne nouvelle c'est que j'ai
à nouveau fin donc voilà le salut se
trouve dans l'assiette une fois de plus
est affranchi passé
j'ai du mal à arrêter leur avancée champ
hier le seuil 1
ça la fout
vous
chic et dernier geste il quelle forme
cela fait quarante deux ans tout fier
c'est trop cool mais c'est un échec je
n'arrive pas du tout la marée palace et
finir le vendée globe s'agit donc pas du
tout à coller mon match le but c'était
de d'être la plus authentique possible
et
voilà après c'était lâchers d'eau
maladière
j'allais arriver sous l'australie en
fait et j'ai eu la chance dans la
deuxième partie pour moi de l'océan
indien d'avoir des conditions
relativement calme où vas tu dors
profiter du soleil et profiter tout
simplement de la mer et avoir vraiment
un manque de relâchement et ouais c'est
des moments où on a envie d'être nulle
part ailleurs on est juste content
d'être là où on est à partir du
cinquième ou sixième jour j'ai pleuré de
joie tous les jours en fait le premier
albatros ou juste une lumière un nuage
ou enfin juste une sensation de quelques
instants gens voient la l2 où on est
juste bien là où on est et ça c'est des
moments de joie hyper fort il ya une
grosse partie c'est que de la flotte
savait que de l'eau on voit pas du tout
de terre mais malgré ça c'est tout le
temps changeant les lumières sont
incroyables et des couleurs qui sont
uniques dans les mers du sud
et puis en plus quand on a la chance
parfois de croiser des petits bouts de
terre que peu d'êtres humains vont voir
donc comment j'ai vu des îles dans
l'atlantique sud j'ai vu
le bout de la terre de feu j'ai vu les
des étages et après le cap horn et est
assez assez assez compétent
la couleur de la mer entre les alizés
l'équateur et le milieu des mers du sud
c'est si ça n'a rien à voir c'est pas du
tout pareil ça même pas la même odeur
quand on arrive dans les mers du sud et
qu'on voit à nos premier albatros et un
peu c'est un peu comme passer le cap
horn c'est s'est fait un cadeau
moi j'ai notamment souvenirs à un moment
dans les mers du sud avant une tempête
justement où j'ai ralenti
j'ai eu cet albatros d'un coup qui le
suivaient ce qui est assez rare d'avoir
autant d'un coup et qui volait très
proche de mon bateau et et dans des
conditions qui faisait que je pouvais
être dehors à les admirer et ça c'est
des moments qui restent gravés dans la
mémoire à plat un petit battement des
blessés thème assez rare
amos qui m'a permis de faire ça c'est
d'être un peu dur au mal d'avoir le goût
de l'effort de pas avoir besoin d'un
confort de vie trop grand quoi voilà je
me suis pas laver pendant un mois et
demi dans les mers du sud et ça me pose
pas trop de problèmes et est et ne pas
avoir de fin voilà de d'accepter de la
fatigue de mal manger voilà terre jeu
j'aime bien prendre une douche chaude
j'aime bien un lit confortable je suis
pas un être solitaire j'aime bien le
contact humain et en mer je deviens un
autre devient autre chose donc c'est
assez fascinant
ouais c'est sûr que je n'étais pas du
tout parti là dedans à la base un mois
j'étais lycéen au lycée fin à dos et
puis après au lycée jeune adulte j'ai
jamais été très sûr de moi fin je savais
pas trop ce que je voulais faire de ma
vie je n'avais pas un plan de carrière
j'ai atterri en prépa parce que j'aimais
l'histoire géo les maths
ensuite j'ai hâte et un école de
commerce alors j'avais pas trop ce que
c'était fin et je me suis un peu laissé
porter jusqu'au jour où j'ai décidé
vraiment de deux mois mais ses parts et
faire un véritable choix et de venir
m'installer en bretagne puis ensuite de
me lancer dans mon premier projet de
voile donc de traçage antique en
solitaire sur un petit bateau de six
mètres 50
mais finalement ça m'a changé ma vie
mais je n'aurais jamais pu imaginer ce
que ça allait engendrer comme ce que ça
pouvait avoir comme conséquence air
c'est aussi quelque chose que que j'ai
découvert en découvrant la cour se lâche
c'est le lâcher prise sur le quotidien
est sûre je fais de moins en moins de
plans et ça me rend de plus en plus
heureuse donc voilà donc on verra bien
mais jusqu'à la prochaine
[Musique]